[Music]
on today's show we talk about family
members and vaccines
and boundaries we talked about
postpartum anxiety
and we talk about what happens when your
body's got a problem with drinking
and you don't know what to do next stay
tuned hey what's up this is john with
the dr
john deloney show and we're so glad
you're here
island's in the stream that it's what we
are what's the next word there
and then say no one in between how can
we be wrong
sail away with me to another world and
we'll rely on yeah
from one lover to another
james has just got his face in his hands
listen
i love it i love where we're ending the
show with lyrics and we're starting the
show with singing
the past two shows we've done that i
think that whatever song
happens to be in my head at the time
that you roll this
this hippity-hoppity punk rock song that
we have
it's like from some catalogue i think
that
we should the world deserves to know the
song in my head
you know what people who say that drive
me crazy the world deserves to know
what's it they don't
absolutely nobody cares just do your
thing you do your thing
but from one lover to another oh
if you want to be on this show give us a
shout at 1-844-693-3291 can
leave a message and kelly will call you
back
or not but i she probably will she'll
give you a call or you can
um write me an email at ask john ramsey
solutions dot com or go to johnalone.com
show fill out the form hey kelly do more
people call or
write oh definitely email the form the
form the form they fill out the form
that's the way most of them come in
and by the way um to those of you who
are invested in this
competition here those who are
pro horse noise y'all are getting behind
there's been a whole new wave of people
who are
fully team james here who have had
enough
of any sort of animal noise on this show
at all which is a catastrophe but such
it is at this point i've just given up
and i'm just letting you do whatever
you're going to do but we've also gotten
a lot of emails
defending the grammar police and last
show you said
i'm gonna send in the cal the calvary
again again
again that's where jesus died i was
not a horse and a soldier um i did
speak this week in front of like 3 000
people
and i said drowning again i guess
and james like part of our soul died
when we when we were listening to you i
know
dude it's like look how smart i am
everybody i got a low self-esteem i
gotta tell you about all these degrees
and i'm drowning what an idiot it's
endearing at this point it's not it's
embarrassing
it's it's endearing if it's not you
anyway i'm so glad that you're here
allen's in let's go to deb let's go to
deb in richmond virginia deb how are you
this morning
i am doing well how are you you can tell
that probably not great i need to
practice my show openers i'm actually
doing awesome
i just need to get my stuff together a
little bit better i'm so glad that we
get to talk this morning what can i do
to help how are you
okay i'm doing all right so first of all
thank you for taking my call appreciated
and i wanted to
get your opinion on a situation with our
grown kids they're in our 30s
and my husband and i are in our 50s
and they pretty much have given us an
ultimatum that we either
get the coveted vaccine or they will not
come visit us
okay do they have little ones too
they do not okay so it's just them yeah
so tell me what's on your heart and mind
so first of all we got this in an email
okay and when i first read it i was
beyond livid so i haven't responded
because
i don't want to speak in anger that
never works out well
hey can i high-five you for that that's
big right
deb you're getting old thank you you're
getting all growed up that's such a good
move
this is new deb right
well no uh well maybe the last
decade or so yeah trying not just trying
to get more
control of anger and you know just
not speak in anger anyway you're making
my heart feel good
all right so you got raged out and then
what
and so been thinking about i've been
praying about it just feel
like and my husband as well we both feel
like that
we're being manipulated that we're not
our feelings towards getting the vaccine
have not been respected and in fact
neither one of us can really remember
either of our kids asking us why
at you know that we're undecided at this
point
so um we just have all these
emotions going through our minds and you
know there's a teeny teeny part of me
that
is thinking should i even be getting
upset i mean this is family
family is family family is important
yeah our kids are everything to us so
are we okay i mean is it okay to let
this vaccine get in the way of the
relationship
that seems so wrong on one level yeah
so anyway just calling to oh i love it i
love it okay
so i'm gonna ask some easy questions and
then some hard ones okay
okay and i'm gonna mix them all up so
you don't know which one's coming is
that cool
okay yeah so what is it about
you and or your husband uh this one's
gonna be not fair i'm coming out of the
gate hard okay
what is it about you and your husband
that you're is it your son or your
daughter it's both our kids
oh both your kids okay what is it about
both of your kids that they felt like
they could not talk to you they had to
send you an email
what is it about your environment that
or the way that you have responded
things to the past what was it about
their
their fear level with you that they felt
like they had to do this
in an email
well i had not thought about it from
that angle
but in the past from their perspective
it's always been good to have a record
of what's been said so that later on we
can go back
and he said what about what
so is there anything i haven't thought
that maybe they don't feel
faith coming to us and actually talking
to us and
one thing you do need to know is that
both of them are out of state
sure sure so that makes it a little
different what about the past that they
felt like they needed a record
have they told you all something and
then y'all go ahead and do what you want
to do
or you think they said one thing and
they think you said one thing so now
we're putting everything in writing
um i think it's more been something that
they've learned from
family members that it's always good to
have a record
yeah but now with you i mean if if i
know
i do that for like we're gonna our
flight's gonna be in at three o'clock
and my fam i come by my adhd naturally i
come by
it very environmentally um
i earned it and i learned it how about
that and so it's good
for my parents to know when i'm like
what time our flight's arriving right or
when our family's gonna come or that
this year we're having
dinner at their house but we're gonna
have the lunch of thanksgiving at my
in-laws house those kind of things are
good
right to make sure they're in writing
because those are details
a relational conversation saying hey we
don't feel safe
um we don't want to be the ones that get
you and mom sick or you and dad sick
or we're worried about y'all something
heavy
man to have to sit down and go first
with an email
tells me there's some something about
that dynamic and it could be that
they're childish and they
are throwing a temper tantrum and being
brats and they're lawyers
and that's just how they choose to
interact with the world but i always
want to ask the parents first what is it
about
there's something about that dynamic
they don't feel like they can come just
sit down and say hey guys
hmm yeah it could be
i mean i hadn't thought about that but i
think probably looking in the past
growing up
there have been times where
maybe as younger kids they've said
something and maybe
we've come down too hard or
not maybe not respected their
opinions as much as we should have
gotcha
that's just something for you and your
husband to think through and
that's a broader picture of what kind of
environment do we have here
the second thing is is
when you're telling me this story i'm
thinking about
two parents who raised a
are they brother and sister yeah
who raised a brother and sister who in
their 30s or a
still talking still communicating still
conspiring against mom and dad
number two that have really strong
beliefs
and number three have either
watched this learned this or have
somehow developed strong boundaries
as adults
as as somebody who has two little ones
in my house
i want to tell you and your husband you
all won
you created two independent yet still
relationally connected
siblings who draw firm boundaries who
have thoughts of their own who are
passionate about things
to the point that they want to keep
their parents safe so much that they're
willing to
not see them and that's how strong their
boundaries are
as a parent who's used to running the
lives of their children
it feels like manipulation but i want to
flip it around and
it's and tell you that it's a boundary
and you should celebrate it
even when the boundary is against you
but that's not fair it is yeah it is
because now you're into the crappy part
of parenting which is
little johnny and susie grow up and they
turn into adults
and you can't run their life anymore and
you can't control them you can't make
them do anything
you just can love them you and
man you can play hardball like well then
we're not gonna we're gonna cut you out
of the will
that hurts you guys you know what i mean
that hurts you guys yeah you can
you can love them you can give them your
parent advice you can even say
all right mom mom advice and i'm mom and
i get to say whatever i want and then
you give your advice and then you can
say
all right y'all can all roll your eyes
now but i said it's so hot you could do
that all you want
but at this point it's about
relationship and there's nothing more
heartbreaking for me
than watching a 60 year old parent
try to treat their 40 year old daughter
like she's 11. it breaks my heart right
because you're you're ruining what could
be
a world-class hilarious fun
nobody knows us better relationship
right
and it's one of still power and
overlording and it just the whole the
whole dynamic is
you're trying to hang on to it and man
all you're doing you're just gonna lose
that 40 year old
right they're out unless you're gonna
take your money for your car or whatever
i know grown kids who are like their
parents are 50
that are still in their parents cell
phone plan like because it's a good deal
man
come on dude so here's the last thing
you asked me
is the covid vaccine worth
the relationship this doesn't sound like
a coveted vaccine
a medical question for me this sounds
like you don't like
your kids drawing a real firm boundary
put backing you and your husband into a
corner and it sounds like y'all are
folks who don't like being backed into a
corner especially by your two snot and
those little kids
and you'll show them is that more like
it or do you have a
true scientific we believe the science
around the vaccine
is going to kill us and we don't want to
die to the point that we're not going to
be around our kids
no we have concerns about getting it and
we're not completely against it we just
haven't decided at this point but i
think the big thing for us
is that they have not
asked us why they haven't tried to
understand
our position and you know we know their
persist
position and we respect it and but it
really pisses you off yeah not so much
now because it's
you know it's been a couple of weeks
okay and we have we have text and talked
in between so it's not like they gave
this and we haven't spoken
at all so that's good but it's just more
that they
haven't tried to understand us they
haven't respected us
they had said that um they respected
other people for
not getting it that was their choice if
they get coveted
you know that was all their choice but
because we're their
parents they feel very strongly
that we should get it sure because you
know and i know that
part of that comes out of love i would
say i would say a hundred percent of it
comes out of love
a hundred percent of them want they
think that they
know what's best for their mom and dad
and so they're gonna they're willing to
sacrifice that relationship for y'all's
health that's what it sounds like to me
um i if i'm you here's what i would do
i would respond to that email and say
thank y'all so so so much
for still working together as brother
and sister thank y'all for
putting your hearts out here and i would
also say i'm so
sorry that your dad and i have not
created a home
that we could have this conversation
first before it turned in before y'all
felt like you had to write something
your dad and i really want to talk to
you guys about this
and so when y'all if if and when y'all
are ready to have like a
zoom call or a four-way call we'd love
to have a conversation about this
in person and i would approach it that
way
because what you're doing there is
you're recognizing the strength of the
way you trained your kids
which is to have strong opinions to back
it up to love the people in their world
and to have boundaries y'all trained him
to do that good for you that means you
raised good humans
and number two you are owning the fact
that somewhere along the way
you and your husband created a home
environment that was not conducive to
your kids calling and saying
hey dad i'm worried about you hey mom
i don't like the way this is happening
and you can say i don't care what you
like i'm your mom i can do whatever i
want
and that goes back and forth but there's
something there so if you go first and
just own it
and then it lets all the air out of that
drama like we sent the email we're
waiting on the reply
it lets all that air out of the drama
all the drama
the air out of that drama balloon right
it's gone
and then y'all can get to the actual
route here which is
you want to have a relationship with
your kids they want to have a
relationship with you
so much that they've weaponized the
relationship you're thinking about
weaponizing it back
and then this gives you guys an even
playing field to have the hard
conversation
and then the reality is if y'all gonna
get the code vaccine go get it man
and then tell your kids thanks for
loving us and then move on this whole
thing's over
right or you could say we are absolutely
not getting it
we're going to war and we're mom and dad
and we're bigger than you and we own the
house and we're going to leave it to
your idiot cousin right whatever you
want to do
okay does that make sense all right it
does and that um
helps me to word the email a little bit
better helps us to word it better
the shorter the better the shorter the
better that's always good
and hey that's a real baller power move
too
not that we're doing we're not doing
power here but it's a really dope power
move just to write back
hey thank you all so much we love that
y'all did this
when y'all are ready to have a
conversation with us we'll set up the
zoom call we'll do that
sounds angry or frustrated or anything
i wasn't going to give my opinion on
this no the vaccine's not worth your
relationship
for crying out loud it's not those are
your kids they love you you love them
it's not but that's just my opinion such
it is
all right let's go to
katherine in atlanta georgia
katherine good morning how are you hey
dr doloni i'm doing good what are you
doing
you having fun uh you could say that
um i wanted to ask you this
relates to having fun i'm exhausted
i have a newborn and i know
i've heard you talk a lot about
postpartum depression
yes and so coming out of giving birth i
was kind of anticipating that
and i did not realize that postpartum
anxiety was a
well number one i feel like i always
have to give this disclaimer
disclaimer i haven't nor will i ever
have a kid i've never experienced this
and there's nothing worse than some
man somewhere giving a woman advice on
how her body should be feeling
that's super annoying right can we all
just agree on that is that cool same
team same team okay good
now i have sat and walked alongside
a bajillion not a bajillion that's a
little bit overstated
um the number of women who
again i've never experienced any of
these i have heard more
horror stories about postpartum anxiety
then i have postpartum depression
okay that it is brutal
um walk me through some of your
experiences
um okay well there's been a
hold few yeah you are the most lovely
person i've talked to today and i talked
to james
i talked to james and he's usually the
most lovely you are because
you're like okay i'll describe it and i
know
you're about to describe some really
awful stuff in your spears
you're just oh you're so wonderful okay
so go for it
how's your little one by the way she is
five weeks she was born premature though
so she's like
two basically like two weeks if you if
we went full term
so um that in and of itself had some
anxiety tied to it but
the kind of what more i'm looking for
advice on
is so like for example kind of
the two things that really get to me the
most are at night like when i'm trying
to sleep
and then when i'm driving in the car and
like i'll be
driving this is probably the best one to
start with i'll be driving
and like she'll be in the back seat and
i'll just be thinking like
i haven't heard her make a noise in a
while i need to like pull over and see
if she's okay
or like i just think in my head like oh
what if we get in a car accident and
then she just
i mean she's in her seat so she nothing
should happen but i just
think like oh this is gonna happen or um
at night it's kind of the same thing
where i'm like trying to sleep
but then i think oh well she's making a
lot of noise maybe she's not breathing
okay or
or the opposite i'll say i haven't heard
her maybe she's not breathing at all
and then i just like i can't sleep or
i'm like constantly like trying to wake
my husband up like hey can you go check
on the baby
and it's just exhausting
never mind the fact that i'm just not
sleeping but it's exhausting to be
constantly thinking like
something is wrong or something is about
to be wrong
and if i'm not fully present
there you know it's going to be all my
fault and then
she's going to be gone and all this
stuff yes yes so number one thank you
for saying those things out loud because
i know they're scary to say out loud
right um and they make you feel crazy
and in the in the moment they feel
super real right so it's both hands
right
um have you had any intrusive thoughts
about that they thought just pops in
your head like about hurting the baby
or about just running out the door and
leaving i mean have you had any of those
two
or is it mostly the ruminating in the
worst casing
it's mostly the worst casing and i would
say
like it really comes and i just can't
get it out of my head like
another example and that's it's a little
bit more extreme i think
um the first day that i was home by
myself
with the baby there was like a
tornado warning and i literally was like
one foot in the bathroom one foot out of
the bathroom like i can't hear the i
can't hear the sirens i don't know if
there are sirens at all
and i couldn't i just couldn't get past
this like what do i do do i
stay in the bathroom for the next six
hours so that in case i can't hear the
sirens were okay
or like you i just i just couldn't
function as really good work to put like
i just couldn't do anything i
kind of that's right what do i do that's
right yeah
so i've got good news for you okay
you're not crazy thank you
you're right exactly where you need to
be and it's super frustrating
and annoying and exhausting
and you're you're okay okay
all right so the the nerd word for worst
casing is catastrophizing
and worrying like ruminating it feels
like
you're those are productive thoughts
because you're just on a
loop right on a record player that's
going 100 miles an hour but you feel
like you're
it's good thinking because you're trying
to solve problems like i'll just do this
and i'll turn the wheel this way and if
this happens
i'll just get up i'll just get up i'll
just get up right so
um and then you you said it so perfectly
those lead to not sleeping
which then set off your every anxiety
alarm you have
because sleep is the magic cure for
almost
everything right and then you're not
sleeping
and then you wake up ding dong who's
dead asleep next to you because he
doesn't know any of this is going on
and he wants to be like great husband
but doesn't even know what that means
and so
he gets up and stumbles through and then
you feel guilty for waking him up
right and then the whole thing just
loops and loops
and then tell me if i'm crazy then you
end up
a little more on alert and the best
place to go when you're on alert is a
screen
to just scroll the news or to scroll
netflix and just to watch things because
that's so good
and then you feel nuts and
you spend a lot more time by yourself is
all this ringing a bell
yeah okay so here's the thing
i'm going to give you a couple of things
you can do while you're in the middle of
all this
and a couple of things you have to do is
that cool okay
yeah all right number one be really
really nice to my friend catherine
okay she has a five week old baby at her
house is this baby number one
yes yes everything you knew before now
is all stupid
right yeah this matters so
much and then you have a kid nope when i
have a kid it's gonna look like this
nope i'm going to have this glorious
pregnancy
and my husband's going to hold my hand
it's all going to be to term
and all the music's going to be playing
and the essential oil whatever things
you i don't
none of that happened right early was
the c-section unplanned um
yeah okay it wasn't a c-section but um
yeah it was
not planned but early labor yeah no it
wasn't planned
okay so one day you're just be bopping
along and then you were like oh no this
is happening okay
so none of those pictures look like you
thought they were gonna look
okay and that's okay what i want you to
do is i want you to write down what you
were hoping was gonna happen
and then smile real big and write down
with your hand
not on on a computer write down what
actually did happen
because it's beautiful too it's just
different
great right and you got to make peace
with the gap between what you thought
and hoped was going to happen and the
way you drew it up the way pinterest
said this all works
and then the just baby's gonna do what
they're gonna do on
when it comes to delivery right and then
yeah
when you're driving when you are
spinning out at night
when anxiety comes over you the worst
thing you can do with anxiety is try to
fight it
anxiety can't kill you okay so
when you have those thoughts in your
head like oh my gosh i'm getting a wreck
and you start holding the
the the steering wheel tighter right and
you keep checking the rear view mirror
checking and checking and checking
katherine your baby's okay what i want
you to do there is to say these words
i'm anxiety right now or i'm worrying or
come up with some word that has more
swear words in it that's the way i would
do it
just call it out that it's happening and
what that does for you is it separates
the immediate fear as though a lion is
coming after you
it separates that towards oh my body's
just lost its mind again
it's weak it's recalibrating because it
grew a human
and then shot it out and now it's all
trying to restore
itself right so just acknowledge there's
a gap between reality there
oh my gosh my brains on a merry-go-round
again
and then just ride the merry-go-round
until it stops
is it frustrating yes is it exhausting
yes
but it will stop and when it i got to
get up i got to get up i got to get up
begin to gently lean into
the third thing is i want you to write
your fears down and then demand evidence
from them
okay okay is there a possibility i'm
gonna speak really honest with you okay
is there a possibility that
your child is asleep and stops breathing
yep
there is sids it's real right
is it likely to happen no it's not
not even close to statistically could it
happen
yeah but probably not and what you're
experiencing now
is the utter risk and beauty and joy
and terror of loving something so much
and being like letting your heart just
out walk around into the world
and this is being apparent it's terrible
and the greatest wonderful thing in the
whole wide world
so i want you to write down these fears
and i want you to demand evidence from
them
could you get in a car wreck yeah is it
going to happen almost
almost in no way
right probably yeah and then the last
and most important thing is i want to
make sure that you've got people in your
life
have a couple of people you can text do
you have a couple of
friends girlfriends of yours that have
had kids before that have been down this
that you can text and say ah
and they'll just write back and then
that's it
yeah i do okay i want you to
call them and say you are now my go-to
you or my whatever don't give me
terrible advice but just tell me i'm not
nuts
okay okay and i've watched several women
that i care about and folks i don't even
know that well there's been a
relationship with
that have used that to it's just been
such a gift
right at 11 o'clock at night is my body
gonna always
and they'll be like nope and you go okay
good
and is my husband gonna always nope well
some husbands are idiots but
is this gonna happen nope right is my
baby going to
and i can write back yeah probably and
one day you're going to wake up and be a
rash and you're going to think
it is end times it is the world is over
right and you can text your friend a
picture of it and they'll say
no that's just this and you'll go ah
okay right so having a gang with you
and that gang's got to include your
husband and this is what i want you to
do i want you to make sure you're
communicating with him
not in the middle of the night not when
you're exhausted not when
he's all trying to be hero or whatever
um set aside some intentional time that
y'all can just talk through your whole
worlds are different now
he is going to try to imagine when it's
going to go back to when the things were
when y'all just hooked up in the middle
of a tuesday afternoon because he came
home from work early
and when y'all just got in the car and
drove for a weekend somewhere he's gonna
be trying to drag the past
into like whenever we're gonna get back
to that you hear people say like
whenever coven's over
we can just get back to it's like homie
ain't coming back it's in a new world
and then you are going to have this
picture of
oh it's just going to be three of us and
we're going to go on walks with the
stroller and you're gonna walk home and
that idiot's gonna be sitting there with
a video game controller in his hand or
something
and you're gonna lose your mind right so
make sure y'all are communicating
regularly about hey how are you this
week
how are things this week what did we
think it was going to look like and how
is it different
it's never going to be um the way you
all drew it up and that's okay
what's the only not okay thing is if you
all aren't talking about it because then
you're going to grow together and then
that's when you're going to say
man you've been picking up that
controller a lot are you freaked out to
have a new little baby girl in your
house
and he'll say yes i'm scared and then
you can say you're dumb
go hold your daughter he'll go play and
vice versa he could say hey i've seen
you just scrolling on your phone a lot a
lot a lot a lot lately are you doing
okay
and then he can say no i'm not you can
say to him i'm not i'm actually pretty
anxious i'm nervous
a big important caveat here catherine is
this
if the anxiety gets heavy if you get to
where you're not sleeping for night at
night a night or night on end
make sure you're being honest with your
doctor okay make sure you talk to your
doctor about these things when you go in
for your checkups
when you're going for the baby's checkup
absolutely and nothing you've told me
makes me think you're broken in a shape
form a fashion you're exactly where you
should be
you've got a new beautiful baby five
month old girl everything's different
now everything's chaos
your body's still adjusting your brain
and heart's still adjusting your house
is still adjusted everything's adjusting
but make sure you're being open and
honest with your doctor too if things
get scary
go see your doctor things get
uncomfortable
things get dark make sure you reach out
i'm so grateful for your call
congratulations
and come visit us in nashville and make
sure you bring that little baby girl
i'm going to give you a couple of copies
i'm going to kelly's going to send them
to you
a couple of copies of my redefining
anxiety book
there's not a postpartum section in
there because i'd be an idiot if i wrote
that
but there is some really clear things
you
um you can learn about anxiety what you
can do about it and i'm gonna send you
two because i want your husband to read
one too
and look him in the eye and say re read
this for me and he will because he's
trying he doesn't know what to do
but it will help him give a picture of
you and he's probably anxious too okay
thank you so much for your call and your
bravery and
your baby girl is so so fortunate to
have you
as her mom
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and
loud and it seems that everyone has
anxiety
i've been there and so have you it's why
i wrote this small
direct and personal book called
redefining anxiety
in this book i discussed what anxiety is
what it's not
and how you can get back on the road of
being whole and well
listen you are not broken and i'm living
proof that you can get your life
back i wrote this book so everyone could
read it not just science nerds like me
and my friends
and i priced it at 10 bucks so that
everyone can afford it this little book
landed on the best seller list and is
now being purchased by the case
and given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country
i don't care if you're a teenager or an
executive or a 75 year old grandmother
this book is for everyone so go to
johndalone.com and get your copy of
redefining
anxiety today all right let's take one
more call let's go to
tony in los angeles california
i don't even know what that accent was i
think that accent was my pirate accent
lost i don't know man sorry tony
it's all good this show is getting off
the rails today brother no thank you man
what's up i just want to hey i just want
to also shout out your team
uh you guys have an awesome team over
there i totally
disagree totally disagree yeah well and
i also want to shout out team fender
just so i have the chance to my man
hey tony the signal's bad we can't hear
you anymore
so yeah the reason for my call um just
to get straight
down to it is i got a buddy who's
struggling with alcoholism
okay hiding it from his wife denying it
when we kind of ask him about it
bentley come into bible studies that we
host on weekends he's come
at least one time last week definitely
under the influence and then
noticed that he's came to other like
softball games kind of influenced but
it's totally just no i'm fine knows he's
struggled with it in the past
but he just doesn't want to basically
admit that he's been
under the influence and then recently
we've had to deny some of our friends
with driving with him because we're just
not sure hey
is he going to be you know capable of
driving and
some of our family friends who have kids
because he has a you know granddaughters
and
we're like hey we just want to let you
guys know this is a situation
and i i called him the days after just
to kind of say you know love on them and
say hey man you know i just want to make
sure everything's okay
you know what's going on is there
something we can come alongside you
and he's just like no everything's great
um you know pie in the sky my marriage
is doing
great which you know unfortunately we
know that it is a little rocky
obviously because of the situation we
just want to know the right steps we
don't want to
come out attacking we just want to be
able to love on him and bridge those
gaps like as the community to
just to kind of walk alongside him with
this well i appreciate your heart
brother
and um i appreciate you wanting to do
this right
and these are messy friendships are hard
especially when your friends are hurting
um how long have you been in a
relationship with this dude how long
have you all been buddies
so we've known each other for more than
probably five to
five six years okay is his wife part of
the gang too
she is yeah so we're all kind of we have
a really tight
family family group community
we some of us go to separate churches
but we do try to meet once a week
for our study and then also once a month
through a park day with all their kids
and our families and we just try to have
that community aspect for getting out
there doing things and
so we're in we're in each other's lives
a lot um
some some of us more than others because
some of us you know our the age gap is
different
you know me and my wife in our 30s this
mike
and his wife are in their late 50s but
we're all kind of still
living life together so this is a a dude
who's almost 60 years old who's
struggling
yeah okay yeah so this is going to be
hard because he looks at you like his
kid
right and he looks at you like a little
whipper snapper that he's helping
through life
right mm-hmm um
man and he's he's come to me and the
guys before telling us that he had a
struggle with this and it was it was
pretty vague it was probably a few
months ago he's like
yeah you know i struggle with drinking
you know i me and my wife
kind of know that we need to step back
on it a little bit i feel like i have to
hide it but then sometimes
we go out and have drinks together so it
was we never really got like a clear-cut
answer if he was looking for sobriety or
if he was just trying to
yeah not drink as much and we just never
really got a clear definition even i
asked some of the guys and they didn't
really understand what
that kind of meeting was about either
what he was trying to ask of us yeah so
i'm gonna answer this dude
this isn't always the right answer in
this situation
addiction is really tricky i'm gonna
answer this
as though he was my friend okay
and i have a reputation with my friends
that i will lean directly into hard
conversations
okay and i've got friends who do the
same thing
for me i've got friends for that are
years and years whether it's craig or
trevor or john or
guys that i've known for years and they
will say
hey i remember my buddy kevin said
i made a joke about my wife this is 10
years ago and he said hey
just for the record never again
right and he's still a close buddy right
so that's the kind of community i run
with
and so a guy like this you've been
friends with for five or six years
this is a guy that i'm gonna take out
and i'm gonna take him with a couple of
us
and we're gonna tell him hey um we're
not asking anymore
we know that you're struggling and we're
here to be a part of this solution we're
here to help any way that we can
um but we're not gonna let you put
people in harm's way anymore
and we're gonna ask you if you're drunk
don't come don't come to
church right don't come out to the
softball fields if you're drunk
we really want you here um and here's
the thing you and your buddies are gonna
have to know tony this is bigger than
you
this isn't something that y'all can
solve and fix and so
he needs to go to meetings and he needs
to make a decision that he's going to go
get well
so this is a matter of y'all walking
alongside him calling it out shining a
light on this thing
and then saying we'll be here to walk
with you brother but also here are
our boundaries for being safe
i would never cut a friend out of my
life unless it got to the point that
they were unsafe you know they were
being off color
they were being ugly and you know what i
mean
but i will draw boundaries around
certain things so there are some friends
in my life who i
love more than life itself but i don't
have them around my kids
not because i'm gonna think they're
gonna abuse everything but they just
they just they run their mouth and they
talk trash around i don't want to run my
kids
and i love them dude they're hilarious
they're fun and they actually know
i will tell them hey if you're gonna
keep talking like that dude i'm not
gonna draw my kids
and they say i know man sorry dude i'm
not gonna change it and that's cool
we're still friends
but here's my boundary does that make
sense yeah absolutely and
if i've got a buddy who's in recovery if
i got a buddy who's struggling with
alcohol
after the game i'm going to be again
this is how i handle these things
i'm not going to order a beer i'm going
to be a person of hospitality i'm going
to make sure that
that guy has at least one person at the
table not drinking
and if he does order a beer i'm gonna
say
don't do that man not tonight and i do
that and if i know a buddy is really
working out hard on his nutrition
and i see him i'll say not today man and
just keep walking and they'll go i know
i know
and i do that because i've got people in
my life who do it for me
and it's just a way of uh if somebody
doesn't invite me to that though i don't
walk up to some rando
in the cafeteria here at ramsey and i'm
like oh wow rice crispy treat huh
i don't do that man they didn't invite
me into that conversation
but it sounds like this cat has invited
you in he is a
part of your life relationally and
otherwise
and so as far as i'm concerned you have
an obligation to tell them the truth
and you do it with the idea towards
helping them be well and you can only be
well in relationship
right right and so that that's how i'm
handling that dude we're all going to
lunch one night or we're all going to
get breakfast one day
and nobody orders well some people order
drinks at breakfast james yeah some
people order drinks for breakfast but
go get breakfast and then y'all have
that conversation say hey we're worried
about you we know this is a thing
in our group we don't lie to our wives
we just don't
we don't hide crap from each other we
tell the truth
clearly you're struggling with alcohol
how can we help
and let him opt out does that sound
right
that sounds great cool i would um
as cheesy as this sounds i'd probably
pre-game it with my buddies
i'd probably get two or three guys and
say hey we're gonna all go out and more
than that then it feels like an
intervention like one of those tv shows
um but two or three guys and i would
talk about it before you go
um hey i'm gonna do the talking
or you do the talking or let's set this
up in this way but that way
there's not all that weird awkward and
then there's always one idiot that pops
off with something dumb
like oh you know whatever i struggle
with
it's not about y'all's struggles it's
about hey brother we see that you're
hurting
and how can we love you so i appreciate
your heart tony even though you
um don't know what makes a good guitar i
appreciate your heart and the world
needs more people like you who want to
lean into their
their friends lives and um love on them
a little bit better
and again man addiction's hard he may
explode
he may start crying he may say y'all are
stupid idiots and just leave
understand that that's his choice to
make let him know that he's loved
never stop pursuing him but also don't
give him carte blanche to run all over
everything make sure you've got firm
boundaries there
right thank you for your heart brother
tony all right as we wrap
up this is actually the second time i'm
doing this ending today because
i acted all cool and hip and was like
all right the song of the day
and it turns out it was a song i've
already done before so how's that for um
planning
in most shows there's this cool position
called the executive producer
i don't know um housed by james who
would say hey here's
you've already done that song that's
exactly what happened
that is literally what just happened he
executively produced it i finished the
whole ending it was great
mike dropped and then he came over the
thing and said
we've already done that song so thanks
man so
the greatest song of all time is not the
one we just did
that one's down on the floor it's from
this awesome tiny little punk rock album
it's one of my favorites of all time
1983 out of step by the the pioneers
of american punk rock minor threat
they're one of the pioneers
might hey punk rock people you guys you
have lots of opinions
i know they're not the they're one of
the so let's all take a breath
and exhale out of our noses off the 1983
record
out of step minor threats little friend
and it goes like this
there are no words for what i want to
say no description for what i feel
it's a non-emotion of something gray way
down inside of me
cue the music james swell it up slowly
listen that producer producing back
there
you could call it anger you could call
it fear you could call it frustration
that's how he says it's awesome that's
as close as you'll get
that's as close as any of us are gonna
get right here on the dr john dolone
[Music]
show